Bueno pues el ambiente obviamente es
festivo entre los seguidores de resetta
y erdogan incluso antes de que se
supiese de forma oficial que erdogan
podía ganar recordemos aún no ha acabado
el recuento pero erdogan ya ha ofrecido
un discurso de ganador ya se podían
Escuchar Claxons en la calle ya se podía
ver a gente celebrando esta esta
victoria de
erdogan ahora mismo Estambul es una
fiesta para algunos evidentemente la
noche para ellos va a ser larga por lo
tanto este grupo de Seguidores
que han votado por él ahora mismo están
en un estado de euforia enorme el
mismísimo reseteo veíamos que antes de
iniciar su discurso ganador incluso
cantaba ante sus seguidores para después
dirigirse a ellos y agradecerles
evidentemente todo el apoyo que le han
brindado en todos estos años y en
especial en estas elecciones que ha
ganado en una segunda vuelta Albert se
sabe algo acerca de aroglu si se va a
pronunciar al respecto
está previsto según nos comentaban que
hable a las 9:30 hora local por lo tanto
será Entonces cuando de explicaciones
sobre cómo él está viendo esta segunda
vuelta que evidentemente
lo más probable es que esté perdida para
él las celebraciones
del lado de erdogan de los que le apoyan
ya se han apoderado de toda la ciudad y
de todo el país por lo tanto se prevé
que pueda dar un discurso de perdedor
aunque no sabemos Obviamente si va a
felicitar al ganador en este caso receta
y perdón y no sabemos tampoco Albert si
emitirá denuncias de irregularidades
como sí ocurrió durante la mañana no por
parte de algunos sectores opositores
sí probablemente pueda denunciar ciertas
irregularidades que se han producido
durante el día de hoy aún así también la
oposición puede leer esta derrota de tal
forma que estas irregularidades puedan
no haber influido en el resultado final
de las elecciones aún así estamos a la
espera de que mal kilín se pronuncie que
hable ante sus electores y que les dé
quizá unas explicaciones acerca de esta
más que posible derrota opositora al ver
por último y volviendo unos pasos hacia
atrás no
contanos sobre Esas últimas horas de
campaña tan reñida
sí la campaña ha sido reñida hasta el
último momento Durante toda esta semana
ambos candidatos han intentado
Traducir los votos ultranacionalistas a
su favor finalmente vimos que el
candidato el tercer candidato del
ultranacionalista sin anuarse decantaba
por erdogan que malcharolo hacia lo suyo
con humitos da otro
otro no candidato pero que formaba parte
de la misma coalición que sinan a él le
podía convencer aún así se puede leer
que alguna parte parte grande de los
votos ultranacionalistas se han ido del
lado de erdogan recordemos que
glitcharololu intentaba estos
votos ultranacionalistas pero también
quizá olvidando que había pactado
previamente con la izquierda Procura
bastante reticente siempre a pactar con
el ultranacionalismo obviamente por lo
tanto esta última semana ha sido muy
movida a nivel electoral y ahora ya
hemos visto finalmente que el resultado
se ha traducido en una victoria de
receptahiperdogán con cerca del 52% de
los votos algo que los sondeos ya
vaticinaban